make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
okay what's going on guys this is rob
and we are covering
king and black part two yes we are we're
we're in king and black the official
second
issue of king of black i guess it's not
really part two because we we had what
like the venom tie-in then we had the
incredible hulk tie-in i still need to
do iron man and doctor doom because i
feel like that one's insanely good uh
but
we're covering part two of king and
black right issue number two and this
basically picks up with eddie brock like
falling presumably to his death or at
least it looked like his death right we
had that amazing issue in venom where
the whole thing took
took place over the span of something
like was it like 33 seconds
or something like that it's like this
just it was amazing the way that it was
done so eddie broad
crash lands down into the ground right
like like literally hitting all these
different things along the way
he crash landed down to the ground
spider-man comes swinging into the
rescue right now here's the thing
spider-man is like one of the last
heroes standing here in new york right
there's there's a few others and we'll
find out who they are
but for the most part most heroes are
basically gone and the initial thought
of spider-man is like he like eddie
brock is dead
and he tried to race back here and get
to eddie as fast as he could but he
couldn't right now here's the important
thing to understand about this this is
one of the coolest things right and it's
not heavily mentioned here and it's only
really something you pick up on
if you've been reading for a reasonable
amount of time but this whole scene is
beautiful and amazing right because
these guys have been
enemies over the years right they've
been pretty extreme enemies over the
years eddie brock first showed
not really first showed up but when he
first became venom he was like peter
parker's sworn enemy he's like i'm gonna
do everything i can to kill you and
destroy your life and he went after
peter parker's family
the whole nine yards right it was just
asymmetrical war on peter and now you
have a scenario where eddie brock looks
like he's about to die and peter feels
totally ashamed of himself that he
couldn't make it here in time right
screaming for help calling for help now
eddie brock wakes up and then basically
tells peter
like dylan right promise me that you'll
look after dylan now for null himself
he kind of makes this this sort of sort
of funny remark and it's like honestly
how hard is it to kill one man well
not hard if you do it properly no
because all you had to do is like tear
his head off
or rip his heart out of his body or rip
him in half or tear his arms and legs
off
or any number of the things that you
could have done besides just dropping
him to his death here's the funny thing
about this
like obviously it's like this is for the
sake of the story but it's one of these
funny things where like you have
villains and comic books who get
frustrated over the fact that they can't
kill us
kill a character all the while glossing
over any one of the infinite number of
easy ways to do it right like
any one of the infinite number of easy
ways to kill these guys and so it's kind
of a funny little thing to me
but ultimately like the spider sense of
peter parker kicks in when he's suddenly
met by an optic blast from cyclops and
that's when he realizes
all these heroes that were fighting here
in new york they were not killed by null
they were conscripted into null's army
now we largely assumed
this is what was exactly what was going
to happen because we saw venom beyond
right and we saw this alternate reality
where dylan
basically became a person who conquered
earth and essentially turned all the
superheroes to his side
by forcing symbiotes on them and in some
cases if they were already dead
turning the symbiotes into those guys
but the long and short of this is that
we kind of saw this coming right and so
peter parker basically tries to get out
of there as fast as he can but for the
most part he kind of seems trapped
when out of nowhere right out of out of
nowhere
comes johnny storm right now here's the
funny thing my initial thought to this
my
my initial thought was oh my god that's
right johnny storm has a built-in
immunity to symbiotes because he can
flame on right like that's that was my
my immediate thought and i was like oh
no wait a minute these grendels
are not like venom right they're
stronger than that you can't just torch
them with fire and call it a day
otherwise all you would do is have the
superheroes running around with aerosol
cans and lighters
right just spraying down everything in
front of them and that would be it right
the story would be over
like that it'd be over lickety-split but
it's so cool here
because because johnny storm could
easily become just written in here it's
like the saving grace and he has had
those moments right you guys remember
when jonathan hickman's fantastic four
when like the portal opens up like like
literally the portal to the to the
negative
zone opens up and like it opens up
inside the fantastic four baxter
building
and like like everybody's panicking
they're freaking out like johnny goes in
there he's like close the portal behind
me right so they shut the portal behind
him he turns around faces like this
horde
of like like a billion members of the
annihilation wave and it's just like
flame on right and then like it cuts
like it just ends and it's like just
like the greatest cliffhanger ever in
the history of comics
like this amazing moment but but
nonetheless johnny storm has had those
moments and where he realizes that yeah
he can't really just blast the symbiotes
with his fire and kind of bring them to
an end
he goes so far as to say then fine i'll
let off my nova blast
when that happened peter parker's like
let's go right because when the nova
blast goes off from johnny storm
if you're in the vicinity you are dead
and there's no arguing that point it's
literally the sun exploding is what it
is right here like
he reaches i think at or or near the
temperature of the sun when he does this
nova blast right just lets everything
off now the downside of this
is when that happens it's basically
expending all of his energy at one time
of course he passes out and that's
something that peter parker says like if
you do this you're going to pass out and
they're going to take you he's like yeah
i know but it can buy you time right it
could buy you time to get out of here
and so that's exactly what peter does
right he webs up eddie brock he gets
them out of there and then he takes them
over to the home base
the the laboratory of the fantastic four
in the backstreet building now
here's the thing we basically end up
picking up here with
valkyrie now for those of you guys who
don't know what's going on with the
character of valkyrie jane foster now
plays that role and what marvel did here
in the aftermath of jason aaron's run
on on thor uh i love jane foster thor i
don't really care if you didn't like it
i loved it right and your opinion is not
going to change mine but i love the
whole story there but what they ended up
doing
is because odin's son was going to go
back to being thor just like i always
said he would be because it's comics and
everything old
goes back to the way everything goes
back to the way that it used to be right
the status quo is always maintained
that this led to marvel kind of
shuffling jane foster out right she got
shuffled off to the cornfields
and her own comic that was never really
advertised all that well
and she's basically been valkyrie ever
since what does she do she basically
shepherds those from the land of the
living to the land of the dead and the
reason why this matters is because
she has this kind of power or ability
more or less to know how close somebody
is to death and where peter parker asks
how close is eddie brock to dying she's
like well
you know i can tell you enough to say
you better hurry up
right because like he's basically almost
done with all his living so it's like
okay so you basically end up having
peter parker who goes and he grabs dylan
now as soon as he gets into this room
where dylan's being hidden as soon as
dylan sees spider-man
he's like okay like basically like he
asked the question is my dad dead you
know is is my dad basically dead and
gone and peter's response is
no like not when i left him but you know
we need to get you and we need to get
out of here now something to understand
this is kind of an interesting thing
here peter can't really look dylan in
the eye and it's a small thing to notice
it's a very very small thing easy to
overlook
but this is shame right a person who
can't look you in the eye whenever
they've done something wrong is a person
who's shamed or feeling guilt for what
it is that they did wrong
peter believes he did something wrong by
not being able to save the life of eddie
brock again
tying into this history between the two
and how significant it is but once we
end up having peter grab
grab dylan and then head back to the
fantastic four's uh base of operations
there's a handful of heroes here right
we've got reed richards we've got susan
storm we don't really know where
franklin and valeria are presumably
they're being kept somewhere safe
you got black panther here you've got
blade right you've got um you got
charles xavier and
and magneto who were showing up in the
form of holograms and you literally have
blade asking them like open your gates
right so we can basically go there and
you have no idea how many people you can
say
the smart thing here for xavier and
magneto to do is to actually keep their
gates closed and the reason why i know
on the surface it seems kind of callous
and kind of cruel but in times like this
you can't let the wrong people in and
when i see the wrong people all it's
going to take is for one symbiote that
nobody knows about to be bonded to a
person and they're not even aware of it
right
it's just stowed away on a backpack or
something like that and then suddenly
the entirety of cocoa is basically being
taken over by symbiotes right noel knows
exactly how to get there
he goes in just busts into the place and
they're all taken over right so the
smartest thing to do in any situation
like this
is to shut your doors and to say no you
can't get in right we're i'm sorry about
your luck
it sucks that things are going south but
we can't take the risk of losing our
people
because of what's going on out there uh
sorry about your luck hopefully you find
a better way to take care of it now the
x-men don't necessarily
leave the other superheroes hanging
they're like we can formulate a plan
together but we're not going to open our
doors and let you in because we're going
to let the wrong person in
and everything is going to come to an
end the other part of this is that black
panther
starts asking questions says okay with
everything going on here like yes
wakanda's obviously going to fight
but what do we have in terms of like
huge weapons of
power right do we have the infinity
stones the cosmic cube the ultimate
nullifier what do we have on hand
that can bring it into null now the
response of blade is do we really need
that kind of firepower and valkyrie kind
of chimes in and is like you know what
blade here's the deal man we're talking
about a guy who existed before existence
existed right and then like he killed
he killed some celestials he was locked
away for a little while now he's back
and he's taken over the celestial so
he's powerful enough to conquer
celestials he's here on our world and
we're losing
by not even a little bit so yeah i kind
of think the idea of talking about the
infinity gauntlet or the cosmic cube or
the
ultimate nullifier is kind of a good
idea because at this point
what what else do we have left it's
literally been less than 30 minutes and
we've all pretty much been conquered
right in the span of 30 minutes pretty
much all the superheroes on earth have
been totally taken over now
this is when we get the introduction of
namor the submariner now this is a cool
thing here because susan storm is the
one that called him in now reed kind of
pulls her aside and says hey
can we kind of talk privately for a
second and the reason why is because
neymar and susan storm kind of have a
history where they
pretty much just bumped uglies a few
times right like she kind of cheated on
reid a few times at least
marvel heavily alluded to it there were
a couple times when marvel was like no
she never actually did
but if you go back and you read the
original source material she pretty much
did right i mean that's
basically what happened at the very
least there was the idea of her leaving
read for neymar but but namor shot you
know showing up here is kind of like
look like here's the thing
my entire race has been fighting in the
shadows for millennia
right like we've been fighting all these
crazy enemies that are out there you're
losing this war and you're losing it by
a lot right so if you want to succeed
you're going to need
my help right now my people are here and
my guys are here
does anybody here have anything that
even remotely resembles a plan
and tony stark chimes in and says i do
but it's going to be crazy right it's
going to be a crazy ridiculous plan so
he's got he's like i've got this plan
and i've got a few others that i'm
trying to work on here
but what we need to understand here is
that eddie brock is the only one that's
going to be able to save us
and i need to get one of the dragons
from null right now here's the thing if
you're a superhero
in this room and you're like does
anybody here have a plan and iron man's
like yeah man but i'm going to need a
dragon
it's kind of like okay cool let's go see
if we can find a dragon like
you don't really question the plans of
iron man right tony stark is a futurist
he's always thinking in the future
and depending on the circumstance he's
actually smarter than anybody else in
this room again it depends on what
situation that we're talking about here
but because he thinks about things
in a in a far more interesting way and
in a far more a far more nuanced way
thinking more about the future than
thinking about today it really puts them
a kind ahead of everybody else
and so one of the things that happens is
we have this group called the black tide
which are basically like what is it the
things from
uh aquaman i don't know exactly what
they're called like in before dc fans
are like see
marvel steals from do you see in before
those guys because you know they're
going to post in the comment section
[Laughter]
but um but yeah like it's basically
these enemies that are out there that
iron man knew about
that uh that that name with a submariner
didn't think he did
but these guys are powered by like dark
magic but the idea is to rally them to
their cause
at the same time you have blade who
travels travels to chernobyl
uh in ukraine and then basically tells
like dracula we need your help
you switch to the bar with no name in
new york and you have you have the mayor
of new york wilson fisk the kingpin who
comes walking in and is like does
anybody want to make some money right
it's
all hands on deck it's basically like
there's no more villains
in in this in this whole city there's no
heroes no villains it's just survivors
that's all this is and we're all gonna
have to like put these problems aside
and work in unison if we're gonna pull
this off now for iron man's part
he ends up taking off and and literally
flying into new york and then traveling
to one of the dragons right now the
reason why the dragon is being used is
because
these beings seem to have the closest
connection to null than any other of the
other symbiotes that are out there right
so it effectively
makes them the strongest quote unquote
and so iron man basically gets in there
and says okay cool
you know i'm gonna have to essentially
rewrite this guy's dna right i'm gonna
treat it like a computer program right
if i have a computer program that's not
working the way that i wanted to
then i just rewrite the code and then
get it to do what i wanted to do that's
what he's talking about here
right rewriting the dna of this entire
thing to make it subservient to the
heroes and and really to kind of follow
the direction of iron man
as opposed to following the directions
of null the problem with this is that
while he uses extremists and he gets in
there and starts you know kind of
manipulating this guy's dna starts
tapping into it what he starts to
realize
is that these are all connected to a
hive mind now we already knew that right
we as the reader already knew that a
hive mind is what connects all these
things under null but they're all
experiencing
constant pain right pain anguish
suffering it's just
millions of voices all screaming at the
same time to the point
that it actually starts to overwhelm
iron man now ultimately it does not and
it basically leads to him traveling back
to where eddie brock is
and then taking the symbiote and then
pouring it onto eddie by taking this
grendel putting it on any brock with the
belief that once it bonds to eddie
that eddie can maintain himself and if
he's able to maintain himself he can in
turn
travel directly to null and then
essentially create a back door that
allows the superheroes to get in
and find some way to conquer knoll the
problem with this is that as soon as the
grendel starts bonding to eddie things
start popping off right his vitals are
just spiking it looks like he's going
into cardiac arrest
it's too much for his body to handle and
it's one of these things where we don't
know if it's because of the injuries he
sustained
or if it just simply is too much for him
right the nature of the grindel itself
is something that eddie brock simply
can't handle on his own now the whole
time this is going on right the whole
time this is happening
dylan is trying to get the attention of
the heroes right they're like we gotta
find a way to pull it off right we gotta
find a way to get this thing off we
gotta find a way to pull it off and
dylan's like guys guys hold on everybody
i need you to move and they're like no
we're trying to get this off the whole
time they're ignoring dylan right and
he's just like hey
he like screams and he's like i said
move and then like blast the symbiote
like
blast the grendel off of eddie brock
like literally
disintegrates it in one touch now we
knew that was the power of dylan right
dylan had the ability to con to destroy
or control symbiotes right we know he
has that power he's very similar to null
in that way
none of the other superheroes knew and
because they're adults of course they
don't listen to kids because adults feel
like they know more than kids
and in a lot of ways they do the kids
have something that most adults don't
have which is
imagination and so this basically leads
to them realizing oh my god
this kid can be our secret weapon right
we're obviously not going to have a
march out in new york and start blasting
symbiotes with his hand
noah would scoop him up in an instant
right but he is our secret weapon if we
can formulate a plan around
him then we can basically find a way to
win the problem with this
is they start hearing this noise right
there's just kind of this explosion you
have this you know kind of deep
deep you know and then it's just beep
and that's when you realize eddie
brought his flatline
all the other superheroes here and dylan
realized that eddie brock
has basically just died with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end
if you are new here to comics explain
cliffhangers if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you give me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you